originally we thought that you either
were making no money or you were a
massive YouTuber and then you were
making a decent living so we thought you
had to be getting a million views of
video in order to make any kind of
living and it was another creator that
kind of did a what he makes video and we
looked at his views and we went
substitute those are doable views we can
do that if we really really apply
ourselves when we get a little better we
can double our music triple our views
and that's when we realized we can
actually make a living not being this
massive champ
well I am excited because I have Melissa
and Jeremy from good simple living on
the show today we are in a two-part
series with them where we actually just
talked about their five tips for
vlogging they've created an amazing
community and actually part of that
conversation led into this conversation
so I figured we needed to do a part two
we needed to go deeper into how these
two uh non-former content creators are
now full-time content creators making a
living supporting their family of six uh
and also in the process building their
dream home on this amazing land so
welcome back to the podcast Jeremy and
Melissa thanks for being here thanks for
having us well um I shared your story at
the beginning of uh the first episode
I'd love to dive in for people who are
just jumping in right now and just kind
of walk us through kind of your Journey
on YouTube to becoming full-time content
creators you were not content creators
before but now you are how did this
whole thing happen
so I was a stay-at-home mom and I was
trying to figure out a way of generating
some money and so I decided that I was
going to start selling vegetables and
eggs and meat that I harvested myself
from our small little animal operation
to people that were unable to do that
because we lived very close to a city we
lived right outside of Portland Oregon
and it's hard to Garden in Portland
Oregon but people want that fresh food
and that kind of Farm to Table
experience so I started scsa which is
just where people would prepay for
whatever I happen to be growing that
weekend they would show up on a Tuesday
and they would have a big basket of
whatever they got and that was kind of
the agreement so I started these videos
so that people felt connected to their
food they got to watch their salad get
planted and then I would do updates like
it's growing and then like I'm
harvesting your salad and then they
would come and they would get it and
they loved it and it was just a neat
connection to food and that was how
YouTube started for me I didn't actually
know that you could make any money off
YouTube I thought it was just a way of
sharing videos and then I was selling
rabbits and chickens to people so that
they could breed their own and they
didn't they would get them to the stage
that you had to process and they
wouldn't know how to do that so I did it
this is how you process these animals
and then get them into your freezer and
then I did a bunch of recipe videos and
stuff and then
all of a sudden one of the videos hit
and almost a million views we got 10 000
subscribers and we weren't even
monetized we didn't even know that you
could be monetized we didn't we didn't
know anything about YouTube so then I
was like it asked me do you want to
monetize okay so I clicked the button
and I started making like 20 bucks a
month and so I was like I'm making money
on here and it took the first payout it
took four months to get that to the
hundred dollar payout yeah and then it
was three months and then it was two
months and then every month I was
getting like 130 bucks and he was like
well keep putting videos out and that's
how it started
so incredible we're going to dive into
now how it's now become a full-time
living for you guys um and your Journey
on YouTube has grown you know you
started with processing animals doing
CSA boxes to now sharing your guys's
life of how you guys are growing your
family
um on this beautiful piece of land and
building your home by yourself right
your your self-contracting um building
this out and really sharing that whole
journey and story so I'd love to get
into
um uh when so we talked about a little
bit about you you click the monetize
button all of a sudden you started
getting 20 a month but what did that
look like then kind of furthering that
um as you moved into creating these
videos on a regular basis uh we talked
about in the first episode you guys both
quit your jobs and went all in as
content creators and when you do that is
a little scary because now you've got to
actually make income to support your
family so talk a little bit about what
that Journey was like for you Jeremy so
like Melissa said we really were making
much uh revenue-wise once a month when
we finally made the decision to pursue
YouTube full-time I think we were making
approximately eighteen hundred two
thousand dollars a month in AdSense
revenue and while that wasn't a lot we
kind of saw the potential in it and said
hey this will at least you know cover
our monthly bills and smaller expenses
on a month-to-month basis
um fortunately for us because we poured
ourselves into it I think we devoted
ourselves to it our viewership grew
which means that you know your
subsequent AdSense Revenue grows as well
um which was great and along the way in
that journey in that process we started
picking up some brand deals
um sponsoring videos getting more
product sponsorships along the way so it
really just kind of took on a life of
its own and um group yeah originally we
thought that you either were making no
money or you were a massive YouTuber and
then you were making a decent living so
we thought you have to be getting a
million views of video in order to make
any kind of living and it was another
creator that kind of did what he makes
video
and we looked at his views and we went
substitute those are doable views we can
do that if we really really apply
ourselves when we get a little better we
can double our user triple rpus and
that's when we realized you can actually
make a living not being this massive
champion
and so we just said you know what we're
making 1800 bucks a month if we
completely focus on that we put out
twice the video that we make of twice as
good there's no way we're going to go
down so we can you know we can make this
work I think we can do this but when we
made the final call it was scary yeah
but we'll be back here now I think it's
really important to understand that we
thought it was a feast or abandoned
thing when it came to YouTube to where
you were making a ton of money or you're
making no money and you know we try to
pass along people was like no that's not
the case you can actually scratch out a
decent living you know pouring yourself
into making these videos and posting
them on a regular basis so yeah okay
we're gonna go into you said a couple
things Jeremy that you guys are doing I
want to touch on those and I want to I
want to maybe go deeper into some of
those pieces but I just have to ask okay
because I see this happen a lot for
YouTubers that decide to just go all in
what did your family think what did your
friends think you're like hey guys I
know I used to be a teacher and I used
to be a police officer and now I'm gonna
be a full-time YouTuber what what is
that like for you guys it was
interesting I think a lot of our friends
and family thought that we were totally
crazy even though we tried to set
ourselves up to to be able to afford the
ability to even take that risk in the
first place and we had to save a bunch
of money ahead of time
um I think they all genuinely thought
that we were pretty crazy for doing what
we did yeah like his dad thought he was
nuts for quitting his career 14 years in
before you hit that 20-year retirement
or anything and my dad like he was like
no that's gonna be a great adventure and
then when we actually got out here and
he looked around and he saw our trailer
and we had no running water we had no
power we had a generator who goes you
guys are still over your heads like he
was mad
and now he's like you guys are awesome
but like he actually kind of snapped at
me when we got out here like you're
crazy what did you do which made us go
like it was arguably Reckless and be
responsible but it's worked out well and
I think everyone else made these power
had these assumptions not having all of
the information to to process right
you know have a well-informed opinion
basically on what we were doing yeah
like even even two and a half years ago
the whole content creator thing wasn't
what it is now it's not as well known so
I think if someone says they're going to
be a YouTuber now there's people
understand the space a little bit better
but then it just sounded nuts it's just
it's unconventional and people don't
know what to make of it I think is the
biggest thing yeah I got the same thing
my dad he did 26 years in the military
you know for him he was like wait you're
gonna make videos on you're gonna put
them on the Internet and then you're
gonna get paid to do that who pays you
you know like that kind of yeah
non-traditional type thing so I just
wanted to ask that because I think it's
so fascinating
um when you're you're kind of those
Renegades right those Pioneers in the
family of being like we're gonna just
not do it conventional but this is a
real job you know we have people in our
community we have doctors and lawyers
and contractors and real estate agents
that are making more off of YouTube than
they are in their practices in their
businesses and obviously this is part of
the business but the amount that's
coming from these channels from YouTube
specifically and we're going to get into
some of the different income ways that
you guys are generating
um it's generating more than doctor
level income for some people and that to
me you hit on this a little bit Melissa
too you don't actually have to have a
million views per video to make this
sustainable it's understanding that
you're building a community that wants
to come back more and more so you can
build a business around what you're
creating so I love that you guys both
talked about those two things now you
did mention that you guys started with
AdSense with if you're brand new to the
podcast that just means that you get
paid for the content you're creating and
you get paid by Google and YouTube it's
the same company but they pay you uh to
be a content creator which is amazing
because it was one of the first ways um
that content creators could make a
full-time living because other channels
other social media channels were not
doing that yet
um now you guys are actually making an
income from both YouTube and Facebook so
I'd love to talk about that a little bit
and then um and then brand deals what
does that look like percentage-wise
um you know for for the income that you
guys have just in a rough estimate
percentage of what you guys are doing
and bringing that in
brand deals probably make up close to
two-thirds of our monthly Revenue so
like a pretty big percentage and then
I'd say the rest is kind of difficult
primarily the most part of the remainder
would be AdSense and then we have other
things that we do Facebook uh
consultations
merchandise stuff like that right but
yeah the the brand deals that one minute
integration in our video is where the
majority of our Revenue comes from so we
do get people saying like I I wish that
you would just not do that in your
videos and you know other content
creators don't do that and I I totally
respect content creators that decide not
to do that but for us we put so much
time and energy into one video One video
a week probably 20 to 30 hours of
editing goes into that one video we want
to maximize that for ourselves and for
our family so that we don't have to pump
out a video every other day because if
we were doing a video every other day
the quality is not going to be as good
we're not going to be able to sponsor
them because you can't get that approval
and everything with the sponsor and it
just makes more sense to put all that
work into one video maximize it and
still have a life
mm-hmm now you guys didn't just jump
into doing all this at one time a lot of
content creators will hear someone like
you guys who are a few years down the
road already
um talk to me about how you guys added
on those different income streams as
your career progressed on YouTube
yeah we definitely scale things up over
time so as the channel grew
um you know we fielded far more
opportunities with
an increase in views
um and so yeah we just we took on those
new opportunities and implemented them
slowly
are you ready to start or grow your
YouTube channel do you feel stuck and
need help connecting the dots join this
free web class where you'll learn the
step-by-step playbook for YouTube
success we've helped thousands of
purpose-driven entrepreneurs just like
you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com
[Music]
because it doesn't matter how many
subscribers you have as far as the money
you get for a sponsor it's all about
cues they want what are your guaranteed
views so these sponsors are going to
look at over the last 90 days what new
account do you hit every single time and
if you have videos that are getting a
hundred thousand views and your videos
are getting 300 000 views you're only
going to get paid for a hundred thousand
views because the fact that you have a
few of those videos that hit that
hundred thousand that's your guaranteed
they're not going to pay you for 300 000
when it might be a hundred thousand view
video so when you're getting 100 000
views every single video start reaching
out to agencies or they will reach out
to you they really do come to you and
then it makes it more worth it like then
then it's worth putting that ad in there
and
then you clicks on it it equates number
wise the girls are down at the overtime
but like Melissa said I think you should
just make the primary focus and assist
um on making the best videos that you're
possibly capable of making and that
opportunities come a long way and you
get to make the decision on whether or
not you want to pursue yeah this
particular opportunity or or go away
yeah but to look at someone who's you
know three or four years and doing
sponsors and getting a certain amount of
views and want to come out the gates and
do that same thing that's not really the
way YouTube is you have to crawl before
your walk
so so good now you guys are integrating
brand deals uh did you go to school to
learn how to do brand deals like how did
that happen for you obviously you said
that they can't they you would either
reach out to them they would come to you
how are you guys negotiating what does
this look like for you
um where this isn't your background of
making brand deals happen how have you
learned this process over time trial and
error primarily and I think it's been
um huge for us to talk to other creators
who maybe have a little more experience
in working in you know these areas like
sponsorships getting some feedback from
them just to have a general idea of what
the market is and then uh you know
strategizing on our end and working with
your Brands to see whether or not it's a
good fit and whether or not we're in the
same ballpark as far as what the rate of
compensation would be yeah but a lot of
creators don't share that because we're
not actually supposed to contractual
share what we're getting paid and that
the brands write that into the contracts
because they don't want you know that
that's going to be bad for them so
um talking to people you get a general
General feel for it but I mean our very
first brand deal it was actually an
agency that reached out to us and said
hey we noticed that you guys are getting
these views do you are you interested in
doing some brand deals I have two Brands
we want to present to you this is what
we're going to pay you for them and we
want really okay like let's try it and
we were super nervous they weren't great
um neither company ever wanted to work
with us again because they were horrible
after you go back and watch our very
first brand we're like and this you know
they just weren't good they weren't
natural like anything else you did
better with it over time in the morning
to do something the more and more
comfortable you start to feel with it so
yeah don't feel bad if your first brands
are aren't great um you're going to get
better at making them and putting them
naturally into your story and I think
that's become more digestible too for
our audience is naturally integrating
them into our storyline we used to do
kind of like a breakaway and then it was
like a commercial and it would break
back into the video and now it's just
becomes like okay we're in for the night
now tonight we're doing this so we're
cooking this or you know Kenji our dog
it wasn't feeling well so they came to
us with a CBD dog supplement we said
yeah we can definitely integrate that in
because we wanted to give him CBD anyway
so that just it just worked and people
kind of embraced it like oh this is
something that's making your dog feel
better and so I think it's if you can
naturally find products that you use
that you like that and we do a lot with
like Thrive market and that I actually
shop there I'm actually very passionate
about that I share it with people I was
at a barbecue and he's like will you
stop it I'm like yeah but if you join
Thrive market today you can because I
believe in that product so if you find
products that you actually believe in
you can speak more
organically and naturally about them
yeah and I as a viewer of your guys's
content I noticed that uh more and more
that um it doesn't feel like a
commercial it feels very integrated and
I think as more and more content
creators um you know the the online
branding space like uh micro influencers
is what what we're called right you're
called a microphone sir we're a micro
influencer because we're we are hitting
a certain demographic
um that that company wants the amount of
money that's going to flood into uh
micro influencers over the next decade
is unbelievable we're talking billions
of dollars because we're able to reach
people in a completely different way
people are on their phones all the time
people are watching specific YouTube
videos or following specific channels
because that's their interest and so
when a company can integrate into that
content it's a win-win for both sides so
I think it's really um amazing to see
how you guys have been able to over time
really make it just part of the
storyline part of what you're doing and
at the same same time supplementing your
income along the way right because
they're paying you to be able to include
that but like you said it's not just
that you know one minute in or whatever
that looks like for that actual brand
it's you spending all of this time to
create free content and most people
don't remember that all of what you're
doing on YouTube technically is free you
get paid on the back end as a content
creator so I think that's a really good
key to point out for people with brand
deals yeah and these brand Deals they
don't take 60 seconds to make like
people think like if we just sit there
and like we will devote sometimes an
entire day to making a 60-second
integration and they they give you
talking points like we work mostly
through agencies we do work one-on-one
with Brands if a brand will reach out to
us but we work with about eight
different agencies and they pitch deals
at us and if we don't like the product
we'll say no thank you you know let us
know about any other brands but then
there's other brands that we just work
with on a consistent basis which is
great and they give us the talking
points and then I write a script around
those talking points and then we have to
come we have to shoot all the b-roll we
have to deliver the whole thing and then
we have to put it together in this short
commercial and I'll have 50 different
clips for 60 seconds
so it really is a whole process to make
these these Integrations but I think the
advertising is so powerful because our
audience feels like they're hearing
about it from a friend or from a family
member versus like a radio ad where it's
someone that they don't recognize so
let's talk about the future for good
simple living uh you guys so far right
now have several different income
streams what are some future things that
you guys want to add to your portfolio
when it comes to being a content creator
being entrepreneurs what does that look
like for you guys in the future that's a
great question I'm not entirely sure how
to answer that I think just to continue
to grow what it is that we've already
done and we have some ideas of different
things we want to incorporate that'll
hopefully grow our level of Revenue that
we are currently earning but uh we'll
kind of see where it goes on there's
nothing set in stone I think that's one
of the biggest takeaways that we've
we've had throughout this process is
that you know you never really know
where things are going but if you remain
open and to the opportunities that are
being presented to you it can be
life-changing right in a number of ways
yeah I mean even even today and this is
the first podcast we've ever been on and
it made us a little nervous to go on to
a podcast where we said you know what we
said don't say no to Opportunities so
um I think just saying yes to different
opportunities branching out meeting
other creators going you know trying out
podcasting things like that and we don't
really know the space is ever changing
and I think we just have to adapt and
grow as the space changes or you get
left behind so it's always making sure
you're you're keeping up with what's
what's happening what the new platforms
are it's a good answer yeah really good
answer I like it um and thank you guys
for being on the first podcast you've
ever done I get the honor to be able to
uh to be that way I'm excited that your
story I think is really going to inspire
a lot of different content creators a
lot of entrepreneurs who are just trying
to figure this thing out because you're
a real story you're a real family you're
doing this real thing
um you know you you took a chance you
stepped out in faith and you were like
we're just going to do this we're going
to become full-time content creators and
while that is scary I want to applaud
you both for taking that risk and for
showing that this can be done and that
you can live a life that you choose um
and that you have the opportunities like
you said with this ever-changing world
of content creation to figure it out as
you go you know you don't have to have
all the answers right when you start you
really can figure it out what would be
some advice that you have for a brand
new content creator who is ready to get
started they want to start making some
dollars they're really wanting to you
know get out of debt and and be able to
do this full-time be able to make this a
reality for themselves what would be
your lasting advice to them for today's
podcast don't get started and spend ten
thousand dollars on gear and equipment
to use I would say keep things very
basic from the start and grow things
over time as your channel grows reinvest
scale up and do things in a way that
that won't overwhelm you yeah stay
authentic uh find ways that sets you
apart makes you different because it's
hard to stand out on YouTube so you
definitely want to make sure that you
know area or weirdness if you've got you
know weird quirkiness fly that flag and
find your fellow weirdos and I mean just
yeah be authentic work hard always try
to get better and improve and don't quit
I mean if you want it don't quite keep
working at it and if something isn't
working be honest with yourself
yeah if if you're not growing your
audience isn't responding I check you
know check and see where things are
dipping and cut those things out don't
don't just keep doing the same thing and
expect different results good quote good
way to end the podcast thank you guys so
much for your time thank you guys for
stepping out in faith and doing this
content thing showing the world that it
really can be done and I'm just so
honored that you guys are here today
well thank you very much we appreciate
it